foreign
's with us in Houston Texas hey Roderick
welcome to the Ramsay show
hey Dave Christina thanks for taking my
call sure what's up so
my wife and I are on baby step three and
last year my job promised me a 20 000
bonus of us stayed on that was supposed
to be getting this month but now I think
there's a chance I might be getting
fired later this week so when I talk to
my boss I'm trying to figure out how do
I convince them to still give me the
bonus
uh why are you getting fired
well uh I'm new at the role uh the
reason I'm getting the bonuses in the
first place is because they're laying
off part of the department I work in uh
but instead of laying me off they gave
me a promotion
um and I'm coming on too slow
um they want me to be a little bit
better um I've had a conversation with
my boss in August
I'm saying that he wasn't happy with my
performance
um he said I had until October to get
better just had a conversation with him
last week still not happy and now I've
got a meeting tomorrow so I think he
might be putting the trigger on fire me
um I'm sorry that's scary
so you're asking how to get them to give
you the 20K anyway even though you
didn't work out in the role
I stayed on so I could get it finish up
baby step three and I actually was going
to leave
um since they were laying us off but
they agreed to give me a 20K if I stayed
um but if I get fired obviously I won't
get it okay so
the transition to the new way of doing
things when it's done is when they owe
the money it was scheduled to be in
October but it's taking longer to get
things how they want it so they've
extended that through December so I
would need to stay through the end of
December to get the money
what is the line for when things are
done like is it is it a very clear line
of project-based thing or is it just
kind of something a bit subjective that
the bosses have decided
no it's whenever the the Outsource we
were Outsourcing the work so whenever
the new company takes over to work
that's when they're going to pay out the
bonus but they have a deadline of
December 31st gotcha okay how big a
company is this
a couple billion a year okay
um I don't think there's a
perfect sentence or three
that's going to cause a couple of
billion a year company to decide to give
you money if they've already decided not
to
so I don't think I have that key on my
key ring that I could loan to you
um what I what I would do is
Finish Well
and uh it
um it doesn't sound like it sounds like
they moved you into a role and then did
not give you the support to cause you to
grow into the role instead just stood
you over there on an island and then
they're shocked that the island is
sinking
um it sounds like leadership's piss-poor
to me but I mean the way you're
describing this
if we were confronting you about not
performing here you would have heard a
lot more than two conversations since
August
and we would have been saying what can
we do to come alongside you and teach
you to ride this horse because
apparently you keep falling off of it
and we want to maybe it'll get you on
this in the saddle and stay there and we
would be talking about that and then if
you just kept falling off anyway we you
would have known it wouldn't be any
question you usually when someone is
leaving here they're positive
that the next meeting they're gone
because it's been like a whole bunch of
discussion up to that point so that's
what's bothering me about this and
that's what makes me think there's
nothing you can really say to these
folks what I always do in any
negotiation is and that's what this is
uh if he says you're gone you say
um okay thank you for letting me try
this and I'm sorry that it didn't work
out
um I gave it my all but I just did I
didn't do it I'm not really even in
disagreement with you I'm ready to move
on I was ready to move on back then you
guys asked me to stay and offered me 20
000 to stay
um and you know just retell the story
but it's all you know take own it in
other words don't blame them and then uh
and then just say okay so what do you
guys have in mind as Severance given
that I stayed
because you were going to give me 20 000
extra
is that in the severance
and they go oh yeah yeah we're going to
give you four months and we're going to
give you the twenty thousand dollars and
go okay
right and thank you that's very generous
of you I appreciate that uh or if they
say no you don't get the 20 000 you
would say
um
well you know
you promised it to me if I stayed and I
stayed and I didn't quit
you're asking me to leave so are you
sure that you can't do something about
that and I just ask questions
about that and uh under you know I've
always heard under the underneath the
negotiation if you just have this
underneath the words you're saying if
you'll have this phrase running in your
mind that says no matter what they say
you in your mind you're going that's not
good enough
that's not good yeah that's not good
enough that's not good enough and so
what I learned to do is never get in a
back and forth on the number so we meet
in the middle you know you know I'm
gonna show you the car for twenty
thousand no it's twenty four thousand
we'll meet in the middle of 22. and uh
when when you know when I say 24 and you
say 20 I don't say let's meet in the
middle I say that's not good enough
and then I let you squirm
and so I kind of want you to throw a
across the tennis ball back across the
desk at him and say that's not good
enough in some manner of speaking and
that could be it could sound like hey
um you know the 20 000 was really
promised and I stayed
and I was willing to stay
and help you guys get this through I
understand that I didn't do it the way
you wanted it done and that you've made
a decision and I'm not questioning your
decision but I stayed
so is there anything we can do with the
twenty thousand see that's another way
of saying that's not good enough you
follow me and so I but yeah but I think
you own it I don't think you blame
anybody I don't think you uh are are
nasty or unkind or like you guys are
Crooks or something like that because I
don't think they are I think you're
right I think they have the right to
fire you and and they have the right to
not pay you this
um
and uh depending on the circumstances
around here would we pay that maybe
maybe not it would depend on the
circumstances more than we can get to in
the radio call here
so do you think if if they don't fire
him tomorrow let's say they just call
him in tomorrow and it's just another
meeting where they're like we're
disappointed
um do you think he should start looking
for a new job oh yeah okay yeah
um I got a feeling December 31st they're
all going bye-bye anyway as soon as I
get this handed off to the Outsource it
sounds like it's I think the writing's
on the wall but the other thing is if
they don't fire Miss I'd be asking a lot
of questions about asking okay I get it
that I'm not doing this the right way
what can uh you know can some of you
guys come alongside and teach me and
show me and model for me give me some
support on this and show me how to do
this because my job as the leader when
I've got a team member uh you know
facing
crap is uh I'm my job is to take out
some of their blockers
and if their blocker is themselves it's
to add some tools to their tool belt uh
show them how to do it and uh sit with
them until they do it and walk them
through that and so uh
you can't just go
Um run faster
you know I don't know how to run run
faster but I don't know how to run run
faster you know that's that doesn't work
you know it's just and it's like that's
not that's not leading that's Corporate
America crap and it sounds like that's
what you're dealing with dude I'm sorry
sorry you're facing that you gotta have
a little knot in your stomach going in
there in the morning that's kind of
scary but you know the interesting thing
is when you get home tomorrow night
you'll find out they fired you they
didn't kill you
um and your life goes on that's my point
your life goes on and you know I'm just
getting ready to leave anyway so the
only question is whether I get this 20K
and
um you know we always talk about when
you're out of debt and you have your
emergency fund and they walk in and go
uh well we're gonna have to lay you off
and like oh good how much is the
severance I was getting ready to go open
a business and kick y'all's butt anyway
so well let's give us a severance let's
get him a copy of paycheck to purpose by
Ken Coleman oh good yeah I want to hear
his his voice like be excited when he
talks about his job because even right
now even if he gets this job if he
continues in this job he's just it
doesn't sound like he's gonna I love it
that's a crummy environment yeah let's
get him something he loves the job he's
passionate about yeah we'll send you
paycheck to purpose let's get going